solo unos días después de que el nuevo
congreso fuese jurado está previsto que
una sesión explosiva tenga lugar el
miércoles cuando los legisladores voten
para certificar los resultados
electorales de noviembre por lo general
la certificación de los votos del
colegio electoral es un proceso formal
pero decenas de legisladores
republicanos leales a donald trump
planean desafiar la certificación
respaldando los continuos esfuerzos del
presidente para invalidar los resultados
impulsados por afirmaciones no probadas
de fraude electoral en diversos estados
clave las objeciones forzarán debates
tanto en el congreso como en el senado
dividiendo así a los republicanos y
forzándoles a decidir entre mostrar
lealtad a trump o confirmar públicamente
la victoria del presidente electo joe
biden
la maniobra pone al vicepresidente mike
pence uno de los defensores más leales
de tram en una posición especialmente
incómoda como presidente del senado debe
contar los votos de cada estado y
anunciar el resultado haciendo efectiva
la derrota formal de trump pero trump
está presionando le para rechazarla
también
tengo que decir que confío en que mike
pence esté con nosotros por supuesto si
él no nos apoya ya no me agradará tanto
aún así para que el congreso anule los
resultados ambas cámaras deben votar
para hacerlo con los demócratas
controlando la cámara de representantes-
parece seguro que la propuesta fracasará
cuando yo bailen y yo seamos
juramentados el 20 de enero que lo
seremos grove joe biden será el próximo
presidente de eeuu y yo seré la próxima
vicepresidenta
mientras tanto trampa instado a sus
seguidores a protestar por el conteo del
voto electoral se espera que miles de
personas se manifiesten en washington el
miércoles